coming up next on book TV Paul Bluestein
details the economic collapse of
Argentina back in 2001 a country
defaulted on an eight hundred five
million dollar loan from the World Bank
on November 14th of 2002 this is about
an hour 15 minutes
thanks very much I'll just start by
saying that I suspect there may be one
or two people from the World Bank here
and I know people from the World Bank
are always concerned that perhaps
they're the ones who are being picked
out as the villains in a book like this
and so I have to start out by saying
actually the World Bank doesn't figure
much in this book at all it's barely
mentioned and so you might ask well then
who are the who are the bad guys and I
suppose I could answer that very simply
by just telling you what the dedication
says I dedicate it to my children I say
them in the first page of the book you
know to my children I list their names
and I say whom I will always love
unconditionally even if they go to work
on Wall Street so that's that's the hint
I'll just start off with a little bit of
the earnest stuff I I have to give just
a couple of thank-yous and I promise not
to go on like Hilary Swank did at the
Oscars the other night the Smith
Richardson foundation gave a gave me a
very generous grant to do this book
looks like this you know don't normally
sell in the hundreds of thousands and so
you need to do that kind of thing too to
be able to do a book and I'm like this
and I'm very grateful for that
the Brookings Institution was my home
for six months while I was on book Lee
from the Washington Post and it was a
great place to work and I'm very
grateful to the post for giving me six
months off from my from my job to do
this I I'll try to speak tonight about
this sort of the process that that led
me to write this book and in particular
the process that led me to write it in
the way that I did I draw some some I
think fairly sweeping conclusions in the
book namely that the global economic
system contains some serious flaws which
produce some very perverse and even
tragic results where countries that are
aspiring to join the ranks of the
industrialized world suddenly get the
rug cut out from under them and it's as
if there were this the metaphor I try to
draw in the book is there's this country
club
with the rich nations as they as the
members and the IMF and the and the
financial markets as the Membership
Committee and the applicants are given
this tremendous encouragement that they
are meeting all the requirements for
joining but then just as there
you know they're nearing the initiation
right they have the club door slammed in
their faces and they're thrown out in
the street and Argentina's rise and fall
in the 90s and which culminated in this
crash in in 2001 2002 I argue is is
really kind of the unsurpassed classic
example of this genre and the
culpability of the international
community in the in those events I argue
is quite weighty now I hasten to add my
argument is not intended to be a sort of
you know what's called a global phobe
argument you know for I assume may be
familiar with that term you know sort of
either you know traditional you know
sort of far left or far right-wing
argument that about globalization but
for believers in the power of
globalization to raise living standards
in the developing world and I include
myself among those this is a very very
dispiriting story so anyway so how did I
come to write this well I was sitting at
home in on a Sunday in February of 2002
right after the crash right in the
middle of the crash in Argentina and I
got a call from a guy named David
Hoffman who's the the post foreign
editor basically saying would you please
go to Argentina right away and this was
because our correspondent there was um
was had to rush home for a family
emergency
and Argentina at that time had gone
through this is you know political
social and economic trauma they just
there were these riots you know at the
end of 2001 that led to the resignation
of President Fernando de la rúa and then
in the space of two weeks the country
had five people who at one time or
another you know became president some
of them for just you know like a manner
of hours but in any case and they they
were defaulting on their debt and
devaluing the peso
which had been fixed to the dollar at
one to one for the previous decade so
anyway I reminded David why the foreign
editor that um you know you don't think
I speak Spanish to you and he said well
no but you speak economics or something
words to that effect
and actually I have kind of become a
specialist at the post in and
in journalism generally I guess as you
know the lot of newspapers have guys who
who you know when there's a big plane
crash they have a bag packed and they go
and cover the plane crash and then their
guising like there is a civil war breaks
out in some you know godforsaken spot
and they have a backpack and they go
cover it and I'm the guy who you know
when when the bond market in a country
you know really reaches the you know the
god-awful stage and I'm you know I'm
sort of the go-to guy for that that's my
little specialty so so anyway so I I was
you know I mean I was very sorry for the
Argentine people but I was quite pleased
to have the assignment to go look at
what was going on there close up and you
may imagine was quite an emotional
experience to be an Argentine at that
time the you know these bloody riots had
had had you know the memories were quite
fresh these the banks were all boarded
up
actually they still are many of them in
Argentina and there were there were
riots going on demonstrations going on
everywhere these pot bang pot banging
things that you you know you all
probably remember hearing about massive
crowds gathering in the plaza DiMaggio
you know the fabled square where you
know where Juan Peron used to give the
they used to appear you know and give
the rabble rousing speeches so and as I
know I walked around you know the looks
on these people's faces the bitterness
the sort of despair was you know it was
really quite a quite a quite an
impression so you know I also while I
was there talked to some of the people
who'd been in the government when I had
a you know a few moments away from my
daily reporting duties to talk to them
about you know what had gone wrong and
how you know what was some of the key
turning points what was they like and
and their memories were very fresh
because it is all just happened and you
know I thought gee these are this is
really dramatic and well you know I this
is even more dramatic than in the book I
just you know some of the stories in the
book I just wrote about the Asian
financial crisis and the book that that
was just referred to the chastening and
so I
there was also this dramatic overarching
theme of this country that had been such
a success story in the 1990s you know it
was the darling of the the IMF and yes
the World Bank and and the markets and
and what and Washington in general and
it you know it had this enjoy this
terrific growth and finally seemed to be
sort of putting its its history of
stagnation and and hyperinflation behind
it it had this the convertibility system
the you know the one dollar per peso
system that had that had finally brought
stability to this country that had been
unstable for the previous half-century
and now it was such a mess so there was
this great overarching theme and it's
really you know it's easy to forget how
Argentina was lionized in the in the 90s
because we tend to think of it as as you
know this sort of typical basket case
now but in fact in the 1990s Argentina
was was ranked in the 1999 by by a
something called the index of economic
freedom it's that's put together by the
Wall Street Journal editorial page and
the Heritage Foundation Argentina was
ranked equal with Chile for its economic
policies of course Chile is still
regarded as a great star performer in
Latin America and it was almost as good
as Australia and Taiwan of course these
are also you know not exactly terrible
economies and I have I want to give an
illustration of of how easy it is to
forget how good Argentina was this is
this is a illustration that's a bit near
and a bit personal for me because I got
a review in The Wall Street Journal a
couple of weeks ago by a woman on the
editorial page named Mariana Stasi
O'Grady and and and she you know she
said a couple of nice things about I'm
happy to say I don't mean to sound as if
she was she was terribly unfair to me
she said that um she she said that the
book had was had was written with
panache and I really do appreciate that
but I can't resist pointing out that the
following about her what she said which
was that I should have really blamed the
crisis on our
Tina's quote unrestrained government its
profligate ways and the fact that quote
taxes worst IFing life stiflingly steep
trade policy too restrictive and the
corruption of the government this was
the men at the government of President
Carlos Menem who was president for most
of the 90s that this government that the
corruption was legendary and all of
which meant that quote a dynamic economy
was nearly impossible well I did a
little research because I couldn't help
but think that perhaps mr. Grady's
opinion of Argentina had been different
during the 90s when they were booming
and you know not entirely to my surprise
I found I was right I found a column
that she'd written in October of 1999 in
which she was sort of rhapsodizing about
the quote nearly miraculous presidency
of Menem who quote managed the economic
turnaround by ending hyperinflation
lowering import tariffs and dismantling
much of the corporate estate privatizing
even the state-owned oil company and he
point out that the result of this was
four and a half percent annual growth
average from 1992 to 1998 now I'm gonna
be fair to to her she complained that
Menem was leaving much economic
restructuring unfinished and a fiscally
unsustainable budget but the point is
her story this column that she what was
was highly complimentary on the whole of
Argentina's policies during the 1990s
and you know as I say I hope you can
understand I sort of couldn't resist
using this as my illustration for how
easy it is to forget how this country
really was regarded as this stellar
performer so anyway I returned home from
my trip to Buenos Aires thinking you
know well maybe there would be an
additional chapter for my book or maybe
part of another book and in the spring
of summer of 2002 economists were coming
out with all these explanations
you know just many of them wildly
contradictory I mean not individual I
mean one contradicting the other about
you know what had happened to cause this
terrible disaster in this country and
some people said well it was a
convertibility system that you know that
was doomed to fail and other people said
no no the problem was that that they
didn't adhere to the to the
convertibility system rigidly enough and
other and some people said well
it was the Washington Consensus you know
this is the sort of the free-market
Orthodox macroeconomic policy you know
sort of good the prescriptions of the
IMF in the World Bank and other people
said no no it was that they didn't apply
those principles rich with enough
discipline and then there were some
people said well it was excessively
tight budget policy and other people
said no it was excessively loose budget
policy well I tried to sift through a
lot of these you know I'm not a PhD
economist but I I'm allowed to kind of
at least make up my mind about what what
makes the most sense and and the
argument that seemed the most cogent to
me was that Argentina had been this was
the term used by Nancy Birdsall who's
the president of the Center for Economic
Development she said it was that
Argentina was the spoiled child of the
Washington Consensus now because it had
been so admired for its reforms it it
had been indulged by the International
powers that be you know the IMF and the
World Bank and the markets and as a
result it was it was able to pursue
policies that in fact were quite risky
and more specifically I was really
impressed with the argument and this was
advanced most prominently by a guy named
Michael Moussa who was who had been the
chief economist at the IMF and he was
very critical of his former employer
because he argued that the IMF should
have been much tougher on Argentina in
the 90s because during the 90s Argentina
had enjoyed this incredible boom during
most of the decade especially from 1996
to 1998 and it should have been you know
I mean you make hay while the shuttle
all the Sun shines right and and storing
up the grains for the hard winter ahead
I mean I don't I'm mixing my metaphors
here but his point was you know
specifically they should have had a much
more disciplined budget policy this even
should have been running budget
surpluses now why was was you know it
was Argentina so terribly profligate in
the 90s out you know I would say well no
you I think that's an unfair term to use
there there the budget deficit during
this period was about you know was less
than 2% of GDP in a lot of years and you
know this is a figure that we in the
United States can kind of envy these
days right
but because Argentina had it had this
convertibility system where the the the
peso was pegged to the dollar so rigidly
he was it was there it was a country
kind of like someone with a with a with
a bad heart
you know they can't they can't just eat
you know reasonably healthy diet that
have a real healthy diet and so
Argentina needed to have a really good
fiscal policy because it had this very
very rigid monetary policy and and and
currency policy keeping the the peso
absolutely peg one peso equals one
dollar no matter what no matter where
you are that that was that was their
policy and the reason you need to have a
really good discipline budget policy
when you have that kind of system is you
know what do you sort of what do you do
if you fall into quicksand I mean what
if you what if you fall into a really
bad recession well you have no way of
getting out of it using your your money
supply you know the central bank of
Argentina you know the Federal Reserve
Bank the Federal Reserve equivalent of
Argentina Quezon isn't allowed to
increase the money supply because that
breaks the rules of the convertibility
system and you're not allowed to look
you know kind of depreciate the currency
so that you get your exports going
because that's again that's against the
rules so you have to use what do you
have you have to use fiscal policy you
have to use tax cuts spending increases
so because that's that's your only lever
and so that means you have to you know
you have to you know store the grains
for the bad times you have to run budget
surpluses and sorry about all this sort
of technical explanation but when I when
I when I when I read this argument about
what had what had gone wrong
I you know it really made a tremendous
amount of sense to me and if when you
talk to people at the IMF about it they
all said well yeah you know in fact that
is what we should have done so it's our
this whole argument made a lot of sense
to me but it was that was just sort of
the technical stuff I mean that that
would that gave a good theoretical
explanation it really piqued my
curiosity oh this is why had people at
the IMF missed this why had why hadn't
they pushed the Argentine's harder why
did they screwed up so badly so I
started to ask you know I just people at
the IMF are willing to talk about these
things fairly candidly at least as long
as the reasonably decent interval has
passed and and they had two basic
answers the first one was we screwed up
I mean they admitted it you know at
least they should have they should have
pushed a lot harder but the second
argument they made I thought was really
interesting
they said that because the financial
markets had been so abused our Gen Tina
in the 90s and was they were pouring so
much money into the country it made very
difficult to convince the Argentine's
that anything was wrong I mean they
would they would sometimes give the
Argentine's warnings they would implore
them to you know to to impose greater
discipline in their policies but the
Argentine's would say well you know this
was the IMF first and whether mark the
Argentine's would say well oh the
markets trust us you know the markets
love us you know what are you worried
about so I asked some of the Argentine
officials who were who were in power at
the time and they said yeah that's
that's that's what we said so I know let
me sort of interject one caveat here I
don't want to overstate the idea that
argent Argentina was some sort of you
know completely innocent victim I mean
on the contrary I try to emphasize in
this book that the primary blame for
what went wrong has to be Argentina's
the the policymakers ultimately made the
decisions that that that brought the
country over the cliff no one forced
them no one hold a gun to their head and
said you know you have to borrow a lot
of money but but the argument I make is
that they got a lot of help in going
over the cliff from from the
international community now around this
time if you remember in - in again this
is sort of my intellectual journey of
how I came to do this book at that time
there were all these scandals erupting
on Wall Street after the bursting of the
dot-com bubble and they were all these
you know stories about how analysts like
Jack Grubman and Henry Blodgett at
Merrill Lynch you know but grubman's
from Salomon Brothers how they had
touted the stocks of all these companies
that their firms were doing business
with they were they were issuing the you
know the stock or the bonds of these
companies and making a lot of money and
no I mean no one really cared about this
when the market was going up but when
the market crashed suddenly they cared
and so I know I started connecting dots
here and say you know wait a minute you
know I wonder if something like this
went on with Argentina - and when I talk
to people in the markets I mean some of
them is absolutely not
nothing to do with Argentina and but
some people said well yeah as a matter
of fact it did and here's some of the
evidence
so I began investigating this issue and
and I don't want to suggest that I you
know that I found a smoking gun if you
remember with them with some of the some
of the dot-com scandals with with Jack
Grubman analyst telecom analyst at stout
Salomon Brothers the federal the federal
investigators found an email in his in
his computer where he he called this
company a pig you know it's company that
had that that that he was giving a high
rating to for stock investors I never
found any email from any analyst who
follows Argentina saying that you know
this country's a pig but let's let's
let's let's let's pump it up I came away
convinced that if I had the subpoena
power like a federal investigator
instead of just being a journalist but
it's somewhere out there an email
somehow something like that exists but
you know III have to admit I have I have
absolutely no proof and I think the
point here is not so much the people in
the markets we're committing fraud that
they were that they were knowingly
pumping up a country that that that was
you know that they knew was going to
crash it was more it was in their
interest to do it and I have no why was
it in their interest to do it well
Argentina was was was issuing tremendous
amounts of bond size that they were and
when you you know when when you bring a
bond issue to market there's a lot of
fees to be made and as I did research I
found that but that the big Wall Street
investment banks had earned about a
billion dollars in the 90s you're on TV
you're not supposed to do this made a
billion dollars in fees selling the
bonds of Argentina to to investors in
the US Europe big pension funds big
mutual funds and the analyst for these
firms had I mean it was isn't again I
don't wanna suggest that they you know
that they were knowingly lying about the
about the country I think that they
honestly believed a lot of what they
were saying but I think they believed
you know the in Wall Street like a lot
of places people believe what's in their
interest to believe and these these
people knew that the bonuses that they
were going to get at the at the
you know at Christmas time we're gonna
be a lot bigger if they're colleagues in
the Investment Banking Department were
raking in a lot of fees by selling the
bonds of of these countries and one of
them was Argentina well anyway the
argument that that there was a you know
that there was as I said I want to call
it misbehavior but but certainly non
market behavior going on on Wall Street
is explained in a chapter of the book
and I won't go into all the details of
it but anyway you can see that at this
point as I as I looked into this I began
to feel that there was a lot more here
than just sort of a chapter for a book
that that that there was something much
more important than to demand just that
you know the tragic story of a country
that's known more than its share of
tragedy you know this was a story that
really I felt exposed a serious problem
with the global financial system it's
the problem I think is it is it is this
propensity to pump pump up the economies
of the countries that we call emerging
markets you know the countries of Latin
America Asia Eastern Europe and so forth
and pumping them up to the point where
they become seriously vulnerable and I
liken this in the book to to sort of
like you know athletes taking steroids I
mean it you know it pumps you up for for
a you know for a while but it undercuts
your your health in the long run this is
a term I have to I have to say I'm very
indebted to Ken Rogoff who succeeded
Mike Moosa as the chief economist so
yeah it's brilliant metaphor steroids is
really what in flows a foreign capital I
I think can often have the effect is it
can be quite similar to steroids it's
it's it's obviously not a you know
intended as a literal analogy but I
think it's it's it's it's a it's an
illuminating one so what really struck
me again in terms of the importance of
all this was this kind of a contrast
between the theory of how globalization
is supposed to work and how it works in
practice I'm sure lots of people in this
room are familiar with Tom Friedman's
book on the Lexus and the olive tree in
that book he makes the argument
that and I think by the way there's a
heck of a lot to it's commendable in
that book but one of the arguments he
makes that I but I I do disagree with is
that is that is that financial markets
will well will push a country force a
country to discipline itself to embrace
good policies because once the money is
is you know in the country the the the
policymakers will be so terrified that
it's all gonna rush out that they'll
that they'll be you know they'll really
pull up their socks and mind their P's
and Q's all the other cliches apply and
but what I found and this is not a
particularly original insight with me
was that there was you know quite the
opposite problem occurred in Argentina
there was a there was a complacency that
that the policymakers because the
markets were so enthusiastic about them
they were saying well the markets love
us I mean what's to worry about
I mean we're borrowing money but when it
comes time to to pay off these bonds
there will be more people coming to give
us the money so that we can pay them off
and you know I mean this is what the US
government does after all I mean there's
nothing that all that's sinful about it
and if your creditors are willing to
constantly finance you you know you can
you can get away with that kind of thing
for quite a long time and what I think
what I think this book adds to this
whole debate is that there's this you
know this this numbing effect or this
complacency effect it's exacerbated by
that by the problems of the conflicts of
interest that that exist on Wall Street
and and there are a couple of other
technical problems that I explained in
the book concerning the wait big money
managers performances are rated this
also impelled a lot of them to to invest
in the country very heavily so the
result of this is a kind of a classic
case of a syndrome that's become very
common in recent years you know from
Thailand to to to Indonesia to Korea
Russia Brazil and so forth where
developing countries undertake reforms
and they and they this draws a large
amount of capital from abroad and the
capital fee comes
fuels boom and that draws even more
capital and then excessive amounts of
capital and eventually the country
becomes vulnerable to a sort of crisis
that that Argentina fell into in 2000
and 2001 so now at the same time as I
was gathering all this evidence about
what had sort of led up to the crisis I
was also talking to people at the IMF
about what had happened to the - during
the period when after the country sort
of got into hot water which is about
2000 2001 what they had done to try to
rescue the country what had happened
what had gone on behind the scenes and
also talking course to the Argentine
officials who were who were negotiating
with them and I found that there was a
real clear connection between these two
two phases of what happened I mean -
sort of the good period when they when
they when the country was was booming
and and and they were getting pumped up
full of steroids and the latter period
where you know they sort of fell into
recession and and they needed you know
they needed emergency help and I knew I
had a great way to illustrate this point
I when I when I came across when I found
out about this really fascinating
meeting that took place in October of
2000 at the Argentine embassy which is
you know I don't know a couple of miles
from here down around Dupont Circle the
guy came to visit the Argentine
ambassador his name is Charles Calomiris
he's a professor at Columbia University
and the Ambassador told me later how
this meeting had had really made an
impression on him he said to me you know
he spoke perfect really great English
but but I couldn't help but burst out
laughing when he said to me I had never
heard the word haircut used before in a
in an economic context and now what was
it what was he talking about well by
that time Argentina was in quite serious
trouble its its growth period had come
to a rather abrupt end in 1999 there was
a crisis in Brazil and and that had led
to a devaluation of the Brazilian
currency and this was spreading a bit to
Argentina and causing a lot of problems
for their for their exports and with you
know Brazil is a big market for
Argentina so there are a lot of factors
anyway that were
that had could have caused Argentina to
fall into recession and what and what
Professor Calomiris came in to the to
the embassy to argue was look
essentially you've got a default on your
debt and the sooner you do it the better
because you've got an unsustained you've
built up an unsustainable amount of debt
during this boom period in the 90s and
you're in recession now and you
basically have no way to get out of it
and the sooner you deal with that
problem the better off you'll be because
the longer you wait the worse you're
good you know the bigger the crash you
will default anyway so you may as well
do it earlier when when when the effects
will be will be at least somewhat
minimized well you know in looking back
at this episode I have to say I think I
think he was being quite Cavalier in
because you know when a country defaults
on its debt it's an extremely
consequential thing but the argument he
made played out I mean really almost
exactly as he predicted over the the the
the following 12 months 14 months and
instead of following his advice the
Argentine's tried to hold on as long as
they could to to the convertibility
system and to and and paying every penny
that was owed on their debt and
remaining a debtor you know a borrowing
good standing in the international
financial community and as a result this
didn't end up making things much worse
the country's agony was prolonged the
political atmosphere became poisoned the
reserves of foreign currency you know
drained out of the country the banking
system was terribly weakened and what
happened was that the IMF gave two big
rescue loan packages one in December of
2000 and another in August of 2001 and
you know you it's one thing to default
on loans to bondholders but it's quite
another thing to default on loans to the
IMF I mean you really do become you've
been countries that default on the loans
to the IMF for you know sort of Sudan
Somalia Liberia you know you get the
idea
you really do become an international
pariah so the loans that the IMF made to
try to bail the country out to keep it
afloat to so that it could somehow keep
the keep the balls in the air keep the
keep this
going ended up you know piling debt on
top of debt and now this whole story
would be a lot less worrisome you know I
mean why should we care about what
happened to this particular country if
if Argentina were unique I mean if this
were like a perfect storm and you could
say well it's you know this this really
wouldn't happen anyplace else and and I
just want to read one
you know I'll confess this book isn't
Shakespeare but there is one little
passage here that I'm that I'm I'm
especially wedded to especially I'm in
love with as with my own words this is
my favorite this is my favorite little
bit this is the beginning of chapter 10
my final chapter rest easy Argentine
bubbles Argentine type bubbles are not
about to materialize elsewhere markets
have a marvelous capacity to
self-correct an Argentina's default
chastened international investors and
lenders so severely that they have
demonstrated a new level of sobriety in
their approach to emerging market
countries this caution on the part of
global market players should reassure
the world that there is no longer much
reason to worry about global markets
pumping up the economies of developing
nations to the point of intemperance and
my next line is unfortunately the
preceding paragraph is a laughable
fantasy I'm sure there must be some
people here in the audience who are who
are familiar with current conditions in
financial markets and perhaps
specifically with emerging markets and
as you know I mean the technical term is
spreads are very low in other words the
the interest rates that the markets are
demanding on on the bonds of emerging
market countries are you know really
only about three three three a half
percent above US Treasuries because
they're people in the markets are
throwing so much money at these
countries these days because interest
rates in the United States and in Europe
and Japan are so low that big investors
are desperate to get extra yield and
they're so happy to get even just you
know two or three extra percentage
points that they are throwing money at
these countries right and left and
what that means to me is that it's more
urgent than ever that steps be taken to
to prevent other countries from falling
into this type of mess and I propose a
list of things none of them will be at
all popular with the with Wall Street
I was joking the other day with someone
that if all of the things that I
proposed at the end of my book were
adopted the the financial markets would
feel kind of like Rasputin you know you
know shot stabbed drowned poisoned and I
don't mean you know I really don't mean
any of this personally against people on
Wall Street III you know talk with
people and was it some of my best
friends are from Wall Street look like
but I do feel that the way the system
works that you know that this this the
incentives are such that that they end
up doing things that are not good for
global stability and and and for the for
the good of mankind in general at least
in certain cases
so anyway I'm certainly not gonna tell
you the laundry list of what you know
the poisonings and the stonings and the
and and exactly how I propose to stick
the knife in and and and how many people
should be in the firing squad I'd be
happy to talk about if you're really
interested the the important point is
not the details the point is you know
that there's you really need to do
something about this I think because if
we just stand by and leave the system as
it is
we'll have no one to blame but ourselves
if this bubble bursts I really do think
we have a bubble in in emerging markets
now and it's surely will burst and
global capitalism will not spread and
thrive if outside the borders of rich
countries if something isn't done so
it's very much in the interests of those
of us in the rich countries to do
something about this it's enjoy just to
act and to act old Lee so with that I'd
be happy to answer questions
yes you eluded you eluded the fact that
Argentinian Argentine the ghost product
was considerably less than ours is GDP
how much of what you said about
Argentina might apply to us to the US
and what could be that would be the
remedies are you proposing to similar
remedies I love that question I do
actually have a section in the book at
the end where I say there's one more
thing we have to talk about here folks
because the book really is mostly about
what happens with emerging markets but I
do think that there are some very
frightening analogies between what's
between what happened in Argentina and
what could happen to the United States
what is happening in the United States
the reason it's important to talk about
emerging markets and these countries
that you know these countries that are
sort of a spider trying to climb the
ladder of industrialization and they're
almost there they're you know they're
they're really trying to get into the
the top rung is that the system is
really stacked against them in a lot of
ways I mean it's you know one clear
example is they can't borrow in their
own currency very easily at least or at
least not very cheaply we can the United
Stated states a huge advantage for
Europe huge advantage for Japan and and
a number of other rich countries
Switzerland can but we can we can borrow
in our own currencies and that means
that the markets don't have to really
worry about default right because our
central banks have the power to print as
many dollars as we need if we get into
trouble if we get into over our head and
debt well they don't have to worry about
default they have to worry about
inflation because of course if you print
a lot of dollars then you know the value
of your your bond may be may be reduced
in some real sense but you don't have to
worry about default and that's a huge
advantage that the United States has
that the countries like Argentina don't
and the other thing is is it's more
sight justice almost as I don't know
kind of a psychological factor is that
the markets assume that countries like
this one like ours will you know we'll
be able to work through their problems I
mean that the the the system is more
mature it's the institution's work
better and ultimately you know we'll
come to our senses and if we really need
to knuckle down and and and do something
about our budget problem we will and
they you know they don't give the
benefit of the doubt to countries in
some of the list of advanced parts of
the world so and then the final point is
that there's this the rich countries
have this enormous amount of money
sloshing around the insurance companies
the pension funds the mutual funds this
you know it's in the tens of trillions
of dollars and not and it's it sloshes
around the world not it and of course
most of it is invested in the rich
countries it's invested in the United
States in Europe in Japan but some of it
is invested outside and these countries
are much smaller as you quite rightly
point out Argentina's GDP at the peak
was three hundred billion dollars the
United States GDP today's is an eleven
trillion dollar range so even just small
you know perturbations in all this money
that's that that that the rich countries
are investing can cause you know it's
kind of like a I mean this is no not an
original metaphor for me but it's you
know it's like a boat on a big choppy
sea and a big wave comes and you know
swamps the boat so the point is that you
know first of all the answer to your
question is whether we have a lot of
advantages and that they don't and they
have a lot of disadvantages that we
don't having said that I am absolutely
struck as I listened to the debate in
the United States today about our trade
deficit and our budget deficit because
the I mean I covered the US Treasury at
least the International side of it and
I'm secretary snow is quite fond of
saying that trade deficit is a sign of
our strength and you know look in a way
he's right because in order to run a
trade deficit you have to have money
coming in from abroad I mean and the
Argentine's made exactly the same
argument in 1998 that's what I find so
eerie about this parallel they made the
argument that well our trade deficit is
a sign of our strength because countries
are poor companies investors are pouring
money in here and of course it's a sign
of strength until they stop pouring
money in so I think that there yes I
mean I think your reason I love your
question is that I I find that parallels
quite disturbing I think that it's all
too easy it's much much too easy for
emerging market countries to be lulled
into complacency by the fact that the
markets love them and I I really think
there's reason to worry that our country
is being lulled into complacency by the
fact that all this money is pouring and
because you know all of a sudden
something can happen and then the money
all goes out that was an excellent
question and a very good reply in an
area of concern I have a question and a
request next door to Argentina's Chile
which has been benefitting from I'm not
an economist but a tremendous economic
growth rate over the last next last
several years and so I'm wondering if
they if that's a very different
situation or if they're potentially in a
bubble that's one question but the other
is a request and may or may not be
relevant I've been working in
development for most of my career in
education and spent most of my time in
Latin America but some time in Africa
and one of the things that disturbs me
is the United States the multilaterals
World Bank and other as other donors our
pumping have been for years pumping a
tremendous amount of money in to support
development the social sectors
education etc to the extent that they
are supporting anywhere between 40 and
80 percent of the recurrent costs in
those sectors so it's a different case
but if when and if that money goes those
countries fall in their noses so I'm
wondering if you folks any of your folks
have taken an interest in writing a
similar book on that and then the other
was a chilly question I'll have to kind
of plead ignorance on on Chile because
I'd I mean I feel that there's an
emerged as a bubble in emerging markets
generally I haven't looked that closely
at Chile lately I remember when I first
started looking into this whole issue of
the behavior of on wall of wall street
in Argentina one of the people I was
talking to who was was especially candid
about all the problems that he the
conflicts of interest that he felt
existed said to me you know the same
things happening in Chile right now
they're the analysts are are touting it
like crazy and the firms are making
millions of dollars from selling the
bonds you know III think would be
irresponsible of me to to suggest that
you know Chile which you know has I mean
I've met a lot of policymakers from
Chile I think are extremely impressive
people look the policymakers in
Argentina
ARC's always have been extremely
impressive I so anyway so I you see my
point I you know who you know where
it'll hit where the fickle finger of
fate will strike I I don't pretend to
know I've I've talked to people who have
various theories but you know I don't
feel competent enough to say well I I
mean well you certainly have to think I
mean I will mention you know one country
that is in deep doo-doo right now is the
Philippines and I you know I think
there's a lot of reason to worry that
something like what happened in
Argentina is going to happen there I
don't think that's it's any inside
information that someone's going to rush
out and call their broker to to to use
though your second question I'm not sure
I understand I mean you try
about official definition official
development support yeah for not for
because shoring up the economy but for
recurrent budget expenditures in
countries that are desperately poor
Malawi Ethiopia Madagascar have assumed
such incredibly high levels that they're
keeping health and education systems
afloat but you've got the same kind of
parallel analogy at the moment which we
lose interest these education health and
other systems can crash well that's a
different case yeah it's a different
concern because you know here you're
talking about
about decisions that are made by by
officials by the g7 by you know by
people in Washington and London and
Brussels and Tokyo rather than by the
huge mass of financial markets that can
be kind of panicked into pulling money
out and but yeah I mean you're quite
right
I mean I'm if and you know we do lose
interest in these countries don't we I
mean we suddenly get all excited about
about you know the victims of tsunamis
as well we should but often what happens
is that is that money that's desperately
needed in these countries where you I
don't know I can't remember the figures
I mean someone was just stunning the
other is there's a the effect of a
tsunami in Africa every I think five
days or something like that in terms the
number of children who die from
preventable diseases so yes I mean I
take your point but it is it is an
entirely different no I'm just
encouraging some good okay to do a
similar book okay I didn't do my
homework but I assume you had a lot to
do with that article in The Washington
Post today on this okay
are the two things I wanted to ask I've
been always told or heard that countries
don't go bankrupt yeah you know how much
truth that is today but still it seems
from what the article said that most of
the bondholders have agreed to take the
32 percent and are accepting it the
others are supposedly out in the cold
and Argentina keeps going on
going on so I want to know is what is
the downside to in Argentina
except for unemployment which they've
had a lot of and that seems to be the
only downside of course that hurts
considerable people but the concrete
still is functioning well this is a very
important question because a lot of
people are are especially on wall street
are looking at what's happening in
Argentina now and and saying well what's
the downside of just you know reneging
on your debts why shouldn't the
Philippines do it and why shouldn't
Brazil do it and why shouldn't turkey do
it and why shouldn't all these other
countries do it I was just in Argentina
actually to write that article and there
is a section III admitted probably
wasn't as prominent as it should have
been but it tried to answer that
question about why I don't think
Argentina provides a model at all for
for other countries to follow the this
country has been through hell and you
can you can see that just by talking to
people in the middle classes and every
night there are still thousands of
unemployed Argentines in this once very
prosperous country who go out to sift
through garbage to look for anything
that they can sell anything recyclable
anything you know cast-off appliances
anything that they can just get a few
you know a few pesos for and now look I
don't I guess the whole country is out
every night sifting through garbage I
went and talked to some people who we're
doing it because you know we journalists
like to like to find the dramatic
stories and this I think my story was
careful to say look you know this isn't
a you know country where the majority
people have to resort to this it's still
it's still a you know a middle-income
country but if you when you talk to
people the average Argentine still you
know the statistics are you know really
in dispute about this the average
Argentine is much substantially worse
off today then in 1998 and seven years
ago in terms of the real the real
purchasing power of their income
and I talked with people who who said
well yeah you know in the in the 90s you
know I quoted when one of the people in
the article this morning I I had I could
he our family my family could have any
kind of meet any kind of you know
delicious tender steak of course this is
a country that's famous for for its beef
this one guy talked to had bought a Puzo
and a Fiat you know I mean very modest
cars in the 90s and he'd gone on
vacation in Central America he was a he
was a he was a nurse at a at a at a
public hospital and he had five kids and
you know that gives you an idea that how
prosperous this country was in the 90s I
mean they were really coming to the
point where you know I mean they weren't
nearly as rich as we were but they were
they were they were coming pretty close
to our league now you know this family
they're you know they can still have
meat but it's stew meat and one of the
one of the cars that they bought he has
to rent out as a taxi and the other car
well that's this is a little two-door
Fiat 1995 Fiat is what they used for
family vacations him and the five kids
and the dog and they go on vacation in
Argentina now listen this isn't as
desperate as the countries that this
lady was asking about before this isn't
Malawi I mean this is not a the most
tragic sob story you've ever heard but
it's it's a it's one heck of a lot worse
off it's just a typical example of
what's happened for the middle class in
that country and no no sensible
government wants to put its people throw
that I mean if if they if they put their
people through that they're they're
going to be thrown out on their ear in
fact the evidence really overwhelmingly
suggests that almost as soon as a
government defaults that you know that
the government that they fall I mean
they're all forced to resign I mean this
happens in in case after case so I
simply don't buy the argument that that
there's a there's a terrible moral
hazard being set up here that's to use
the economists term that this is a that
Argentina will will provide a beacon for
the rest of the world to follow
because if they really look closely it's
what happened what what has happened
there and if a pilot even this if the
pilot forget what happened to the people
if the politicians just look at what's
happened to the politicians who were in
power at the time of the default they
will not want to follow that example so
but I think it's a very important
question and people are making the
argument that that that a very bad
precedent is being set I I have I really
have my doubts I just got back from
Argentina myself and it is a sight to
see middle-class families the whole
families parents kids etc all out late
at night going for cardboard basically
sorting the garbage from the cardboard
you didn't mention the ratio the average
ratio is 3 to 1 the peso was pegged to
the dollar it fell 66 percent and the
prices stayed approximately the same so
the the prices didn't change you pay a
dollar for what was labeled what what
was you paid a well you pay a peso for
what was labeled a dollar and the
interesting thing is where you really
see it is in the automobiles the
automobiles are the same price because
as a world price on automobiles world
price on gasoline translate that to
dollars it's still for $4 a gallon for
gasoline approximate it's always been
that anyway I don't want to I'm just
corroborating what I think your analysis
have been wonderful there was one very
disturbing thing that occurred while I
was down there men and God elected as
senator all right and why did he get
elected a senator the wealthy people
loved him he kept the peso to the dollar
so they love him they want him back in
there so he can put it right back up the
middle class are kind of desperate and
they would like to see it better so they
are also for them but you talked to the
intelligentsia
or on the street and they know that
that's the worst thing that could happen
for men and to come back in so I wanted
to ask you since you have a much better
view than I do what is the prognosis
well what would you guess for the coming
near future next 3-4 years well I think
for the next three or four years things
are not are not too terrible I mean one
of the points I tried to make in a story
this morning is that is that to
everyone's sort of surprised the economy
is recovering I mean people are still
feeling the shock of the after-effects
of what happened in 2001 2002 there are
as you as you quite rightly pointed out
but despite the fact that this country
has defaulted on its debt and it's given
its forcing its bondholders to take 32
cents on the dollar and they're outraged
by this how dare you you know treat us
so shabbily in spite of that now this is
you know sort of the traditional rules
of global finance tell you that when a
country does this that you know no one
will invest their I mean this is what
this is what the sort of the high
priests of the system will tell you well
you know this country will no one will
ever you know no one will ever take this
country to lunch again they won't invest
there they won't they won't because the
disrespect for the for the for the for
property rights and so forth well
there's a heck of a lot of investment
going on there because for as he pointed
out the peso is now three to one where
it used to be one-to-one I interviewed
the head of a Volkswagen Argentina a man
named Victor clima and he said you know
we are he made this claim I I'm still
having trouble believe it Auto Workers
in his factory are cheaper than
Volkswagens Auto Workers in China
less than $6 an hour with all benefits
one-third or so it's it's it's I mean
that's a it's a stunning thing now with
that kind very good quality very good
you know I mean he said they're 42
percent of workers at our quarter of a
plant Ardis plant where they make
transmissions for one-fifth of all
Volkswagens built in the world that 42
percent of them are college-educated so
it's great quality at low price I mean
this is not something that companies can
very easily
resist now of course you know if every
investor that comes there is is you know
is treated terribly and and and they're
they're worried about having their
property expropriated and of course
money you know money will not go in but
that and I'm sure that our Janina would
get a lot more investment if it were
doing a lot more to show companies like
Volkswagen that that you know you know
we'll get it they will get a fair shake
they will be treated according to the
rule of law but the product you know I
have to say the prognosis for the next
three or four years I think is is pretty
good
having said that Argentina even after
they they give the bondholders this
haircut to come back to the term you
know that was used at the meeting of the
Argentine embassy this haircut of almost
seventy seventy percent on their on
their bonds they're they're taking that
that bigger right down even after that
Argentina is going to come out of this
with a debt to GDP ratio of their debt
to their to their total economy of about
eighty five percent that's very high and
a lot of people worried that you could
see another default in six to eight
years if they don't really buckle down
and take a lot of steps to ensure that
they generate the kind of growth and
investment that they need to be able to
pay off that debt and service that debt
and to generate a really sustainable
expansion I'm working on a deal to bring
Carlos men into Washington in exchange
for marionberry and a dictator to be
named later undisclosed amount of cash
clearly has to be part of that deal well
the cash is under the table my question
concerns the Argentine economy ever
since I've been a toddler Argentine has
suffered with all kinds of
hyperinflation financial crises etc and
you've got a country rich in natural
resources agriculturally self-sufficient
and exporter i think y PF produces
enough oil for the country
you have a very European eyes population
the most in Latin America
why isn't Argentina like Australia well
during the really tragic thing about
this story is that during the 90s they
thought they were getting there and you
know to all outward appearances they
were and you know as you point out this
is a country with tremendous resources
both natural and human and early in the
century as many sure I don't have to
tell the audience this well-read
Argentina was one of the ten richest
countries in the world I mean they had a
very very high standard of living you
know at least relative to to to most
other countries and they've you know I
mean they're famous for their arrogance
from looking down their noses at the
rest of Latin America you know what
we're a little out really not we're not
really Latin Americans were Europeans
and of course I mean it's been a
terrible you know traumatic experience
for the country to have gone through the
past century and you know where that all
that slipped away and in the 90s they
felt that they you know that you know of
course there were doubters and and you
know a country that's been through that
is never fully self confident but they
they really had the the sense that that
finally they were getting it together
and and that they were going to overcome
this history that they had that's really
I think the most tragic part of the
story you know I don't pretend to be an
expert in the and are in the Argentine
sort of social psyche I if I I felt as I
was writing this book that if I tried to
explain it that I would you know the
people who really know would would would
just make fun of me and and and I you
know I just not expert enough to do that
I I felt that what I had a story to tell
about was how these international
economic forces had had really helped
push the country in this tragic
direction that it took and that it's you
know it's important for the Argentine's
to come to grips with exactly the the
things you're talking about what is it
about them that you know decade after
decade causes them to fall into this pit
of despair well as I say I I'm I mean I
have some vague ideas but I think what I
think is important for us in the United
States and other rich countries to do is
to come face-to-face with the fact that
international institutions and and and
forces and and and and officials helped
you know really fuel this this most
recent crisis that it's a tragedy that
the country went through I'm not an anti
globalist I swear I'm not a pardon what
I'm going with this statement are talkie
doesn't work as an economic model and
neither does um you know isolation you
know if you have one of the few positive
examples of poor countries going to rich
countries since World War two
they all relied on trade and investment
with the outside world I guess saw the
East Asian Rim what comes to mind but um
it's still pretty depressing because you
look at the vast as you've said the vast
majority of stories have involved booms
and busts and busts that left you not
really wondering if you ever got any
further ahead than where you started and
you know you have to start wondering I
mean it's a principle of economics that
debt can be a good thing we hear this
from everybody I mean a lot of it is in
their interest to say it at the given
times but I mean even John Maynard
Keynes says you know get some debt and
you know spend it correctly and use the
capital infusion to grow but it really
from my perspective it leads me to
believe there's a certain degree of
skepticism that debt can ever really
help an emerging country you know to
take enormous amounts of money from
other people and have to pay back three
times as much as you started with you
know is that under what circumstances is
that really something that helps and and
I started to think about it the contrast
being a domestic economy where
everything is stable I'm going to take
on a little bit of money and have to pay
it back but I have these very specific
conditions for growth and the people
investing know exactly what I'm doing
compared to speculative capital flows
where I want my extra 2%
I can leave at any time I mean is I
guess the question I'm leading up to is
I'm kind of tempted to say that
speculative capital is just a fatally
flawed vehicle for for helping countries
that have long term rational growth
plans and the other thing I had to say
was just a real brief shout out to that
last question um my answer to the one
you just asked would be income
inequality and I wonder what you think
about that sorry the answer to the
previous question why Argentina goes has
had such grief and macro economically
but just to take I mean the first one I
think there is there's a lot - what is
that - what you say but I just to
quickly address that I mean there is the
the fact that at least in Latin America
Argentina's has been one of the least
unequal now that's you know it's all
compared to what and the comparisons are
pretty awful but it's not I don't think
that you can use that as it's certainly
not you know a major explanation I think
for what's going wrong there I mean
there has to be something else because
as as this donor was pointing out I mean
they just keep you know falling into
these crises so but I I don't doubt that
they're that it's related to a lot of
the forces that that lead to those to
these crises to come back you know I
think the point you you made about debt
and speculative capital
I mean you phrased it I guess a good bit
more shall we say fervently then than I
do in the book but I mean I don't think
that that capital flows have absolutely
no benefits I think you know it's kind
of like anything you know used in
moderation it can be a very good thing
for a country to to be able to borrow in
international markets when there's not
adequate savings in the domestic economy
to to finance growth the problem is
though as you say that that and as I try
to argue in this book that
there are forces that that it causes
these things to go too far so I don't
I'm not like I don't want to guess that
I've completely disagree with you either
is there a magic number or a formula or
something that says when debt is good
and when it's bad well there's a very
interesting paper that's it's it's
having quite a lot of influence these
days by by an economist and Ken Rogoff
who as I say was the became the chief
economist of the IMF and a Carmen
Reinhart and Miguel Savastano and they
they argue that that for emerging
markets really 25% of GDP is is about as
high as you ever want to go and then
they base this on you know all kinds of
regressions and equations that I don't
that you know I my 16 year old son he
understands and I don't I used to be
able to do this but I can anymore and
but you know the scary thing is that the
average ratio of debt to GDP for merging
markets is now I mean I don't I haven't
looked at the latest number but it's
something somewhere in the I think high
60s or low 70s and it's higher than the
debt to GDP ratio for the industrialized
countries for the rich countries so what
this tells you is I mean well if you if
you marry that fact with the fact that
there's all this money that's it's you
know this boom it's that's being you
know all this money is being thrown at
these countries well you know one might
hypothesize well perhaps that's not a
bad thing that all this money is going
to these countries because there's so
much fundamentally better than they are
than they used to be and that's why the
money is going but if you look at that
debt to GDP number you have to say well
wait a minute things can't aren't
clearly are not that much better I mean
you know you can look at individual
cases and say well it's better here for
this reason and it's better there for
that reason but to me this is being
driven not nearly as much by
fundamentals as by the fact that there's
just a heck of a lot of money being
pumped into the system and the big
investors are you know they get every
quarter they get
or every month or sometimes every week
they get rated by how much extra
interest they're earning on their money
so of course I mean if they can make a
couple of extra you know 25 basis points
you know a quarter of a percentage point
more than the guy down the street and
they come out ahead of the index you
know that by which they all get measured
then it's because you know it's very
tempting to do that because your bonus
at the end of the year is going to
depend on how successful you are on that
type of thing so you know I I worry
about it sorry here's here's a question
that you can make a parallel if you like
like the first question the United
States given its heyday and since you
accentuate fiscal policy was worthy
upper and maybe upper middle classes in
Argentina undertaxed
yes I mean undertaxed is is you know as
a term with many meanings but it's true
you know tremendous tax evasion in that
country I think they should have done a
heck of a lot more to to do something
about that it was it was a major
contributor to their fiscal problem it
was a systemic thing and part of the
problem was they kept offering amnesties
every couple of years to you know so
that you could bring in money you gave
me this big one-shot flow of tax revenue
but of course the problem is if you once
you start doing that then people think
well I can cheat because in a couple of
more years there'll be another amnesty
and eventually you know it's the kind of
thing where it creates a different kind
of moral hazard so yes in that sense yes
definitely under taxed just a question
you mentioned when you spoke to the
people of the IMF their first
explanation was that they blew it what
does that mean does that mean that the
technical people at the operational
level were not sufficiently competent to
understand it or does it mean that they
had incentives of the operational level
not to pursue certain lines of argument
or it means that the organization as a
whole
couldn't accept the technical
conclusions or perhaps worst of all that
these systems are now becoming so
complex that in fact none of us can
understand them anymore that these big
systems are frankly beyond us to to
predict in advance as to what's going to
happen well a lot of the things that you
mentioned pertain one that does
definitely does not is that the people
weren't technically competent to to to
deal with I mean I mean I'm and I'm
endlessly impressed with the you know
with the intelligence and you know
decency of people who work at these
institutions I mean I really they really
want to do well by these countries
that's the most in some ways the most
scary thing about it as you come to your
the last point you raised that these
things are some tar so unpredictable and
so you know in some ways kind of
mysterious that that that it's you know
even though even very intelligent people
can't anticipate and and stop them once
they start once bad things start to
happen that was definitely one of the
main messages of my first book the
chastening about the Asian and the
Russian and Brazilian crises and and the
crisis in in in the u.s. in 1998 I I go
into quite a bit of detail in the book
about about why people at the fund
missed this this problem that was
building up and I think ultimately what
it boils down to is that they became so
enraptured with this star pupil of
theirs that they were convinced that
high growth was going to continue for
extrapolated it out into the future and
if you extrapolated high growth out into
the future you really don't have to
worry about a big buildup of debt
because you know anyone can conveyor at
a moderate level if they're if their
income is growing fast enough to pay it
off and that's what they assumed was
going to happen
having said that they they were smart
enough to see in trickly in the spring
of 1998 and I go into quite a bit of
detail in the book about this sort of
episodes they were smart enough to see
that trouble was brewing and they issued
they were quite I mean they came as
close as they ever come to sort of
blowing the whistle on publicly and
saying there's a you know houston we got
a problem and the markets just blew them
off and said oh come on there's not a
problem this is a great country and and
another part of the explanation was that
right around the time in the summer of
1998 the IMF was really getting worried
and they were ready to basically kind of
cut Argentina off and say we're not this
is no longer our star pupil we're
washing our hands of them I mean this is
that's putting a little strongly but
they were they were going to they were
they were going to do is come as close
to what the IMF ever does to to publicly
saying we're really terribly concerned
about where the direction this country's
taking they were going to not complete a
review of their program now that sounds
like bureaucratic mumbo-jumbo but to
people who follow this I mean they know
they know what it means I mean it means
that that they really see a problem the
timing for this was terrible because
right in the summer of 1998 if you
remember Russia was defaulting on its
debt and the world was coming to an end
financial terms I mean it was a terrible
meltdown all over the world
and that's when the long term capital
management hedge fund went bust and and
you know all hell was breaking loose and
the IMF and the sort of the committee to
save the world you know was I mean they
were all running around thinking my god
what do we do now and one of the things
they did was they said we need to have a
[ __ ] we need to have one country that
we're gonna pick as our model for
everyone to follow because everyone was
questioning the market you know should
we you know remember the Russians had
brought back the old communists into
power I mean all kinds of very scary
stuff was happening we wanted we need to
pick a country that's followed our
remedies and
do is doing very well to to as a kind of
a beacon for the for everyone else to
follow who did they pick Argentina they
invited Carlos Menem to come to be the
honored speaker at the IMF World Bank
annual meetings in October of 1998 the
only other head of state who was invited
to speak was Bill Clinton and of course
if you're inviting the president of the
country to come speak at your annual
meeting and saying follow this guy do
what he he's done a marvelous job and
they said all kinds of nice things about
him and praised into the skies well of
course you know you're not going to turn
around and say oh and by the way they're
you know we're really worried about
their fundamentals so this was another
factor I mean it just shows you that
that well here on TV so I better just
say stuff happens and and you know this
is you know I cannot say how much I
appreciate your recognition that these
these forces are so difficult to predict
and deal with and that's what makes the
whole global financial system so
worrisome and that's why I think steps
need to be taken to at least minimize
the risk of things going so badly wrong
in these countries okay the book is and
the money kept rolling in and out we
thank all for being here he'll be in the
back signing books which are available
in the front of the store so thanks for
coming this evening if you could help us
by pulling up your chairs on the way out
putting them against something stable
thank you
every Sunday at 5 p.m. Eastern book TV
airs